Salut, moi c'est Guillaume Hachez. Bienvenue dans Septante Minutes Avec.
Pour ce neuvième épisode, je reçois Philippe Van Parijs, docteur en philosophie à Oxford et en sociologie à l'Université catholique de Louvain. Il a étudié l'économie politique, le droit, la linguistique.
Il fut autrefois professeur invité à Harvard et il est actuellement professeur ordinaire émérite à l'UCL, à la KUL et à Oxford.
Le moins qu'on puisse dire, c'est que mon invité est un homme de lettres. Ensemble, on va parler de la Belgique et tenter de répondre à la question : c'est quoi finalement un Belge ?
On se penche sur les spécificités de la Belgique, on la compare avec la Suisse et surtout, on s'intéresse à l'avenir de notre plat pays.
Pour ma part, je pense que la Belgique est un animal plutôt atypique et assez fascinant et elle mérite donc bien qu'on y consacre septante minutes.
Je précise que cet épisode se destine autant à mes compatriotes qu'à ceux qui n'ont jamais mis les pieds ici. Du coup, si vous n'y connaissez rien en Belgique, et
j'imagine que c'est le cas pour la plupart d'entre vous, puisque honnêtement, même ici, on y comprend rien.
Si vous ne connaissez rien en Belgique, pas d'inquiétude, je vous ai préparé une petite session de rattrapage. Tout commence au Congrès de Vienne, où les grandes puissances européennes se sont réunies juste après la défaite de Napoléon.
Et ensemble, elles ont redessiné les cartes et décidé du sort de l'Europe. La Belgique, très catholique, est rattachée à la République des Provinces unies des Pays-Bas, majoritairement protestante, pour former le Royaume-Uni des Pays-Bas.
Cette union se fait sans le consentement des Belges à qui on ne donne pas le droit de vote.
Ce mariage forcé n'est que de courte durée, puisque suite aux affrontements très agités qui opposent des indépendantistes bruxellois à l'armée hollandaise en 1830, les Belges obtiennent leur indépendance des Pays-Bas.
La Belgique apparaît donc comme un étrange patchwork, comme un pays assez artificiel. Les Belges sont unis par un étage catholique, mais sont surtout divisés par les ethnicités et par les langues.
Si la bourgeoisie est francophone, le peuple, lui, parle toute une série de langues régionales. Celles-ci seront petit à petit remplacées par le français au sud et par le néerlandais au nord.
On décide d'appeler les provinces francophones la Wallonie et les provinces néerlandophones la Flandre. Mais les langues ne sont pas la seule chose qui sépare les Wallons et les Flamands.
Pendant très longtemps, la Wallonie fut l'une des régions les plus dynamiques du monde. Au dix-neuvième siècle, elle fit en effet fortune à l'aide des mines de charbon et des lourdes industries que sont la sidérurgie, la métallurgie et la verrerie.
Grâce à la Wallonie, la Belgique était pendant un temps une des plus grandes puissances industrielles du monde. La Flandre est restée une région agricole pendant très longtemps.
La classe ouvrière fut donc logiquement une grande force motrice pour la Wallonie de l'époque. C'est donc sans surprise qu'avec l'arrivée de la révolution industrielle et de la question sociale, le socialisme n'eut aucun mal à séduire les Wallons.
Encore de nos jours, la Wallonie reste très majoritairement dominée par le Parti socialiste. L'histoire n'a malheureusement pas été tendre avec les Wallons.
Alors que la Flandre de l'après-guerre a su développer de nouvelles industries pour rapidement s'enrichir, la Wallonie est quant à elle restée concentrée sur les industries lourdes qui avaient fait sa gloire.
Grave erreur, puisque petit à petit, les mines de charbon ont dû fermer et la sidérurgie wallonne a aujourd'hui perdu toute compétitivité.
La Wallonie est aujourd'hui une région très pauvre et un jeune Wallon sur quatre vit sous le seuil de pauvreté. On retiendra deux conséquences à cela.
D'abord, un impact important sur la criminalité, qui est bien plus présente en Wallonie qu'en Flandre. Et ensuite, le fait que l'argent du contribuable flamand, qui est nettement plus riche, va souvent servir à aider la Wallonie.
C'est le mélange d'inégalités économiques très marquées, de communautarisme linguistique, voire parfois de racisme à l'égard des Wallons, qui a contribué, depuis une quarantaine d'années, à renforcer les tensions politiques et même le séparatisme.
Ces tensions culminent vers la fin des années soixante à l'Université catholique de Louvain. L'université disposait, bien qu'elle fût située en Flandre, d'une section francophone.
Il y avait là, aux yeux de nombreux Flamands, un non-respect total du droit du sol et du principe de territorialité linguistique.
En gros, en Flandre, on parle le néerlandais. Un point c'est tout. Les francophones sont chassés et doivent fonder un nouveau campus en Wallonie.
On appelle cette crise le Walen buiten, les Wallons dehors. À la même occasion, tous les partis politiques doivent se scinder en deux : une version francophone et une version néerlandophone.
Peu de temps après, le Vlaams Blok, qui est un parti indépendantiste flamand et ouvertement xénophobe, connaît une lente ascension, jusqu'à recueillir vingt-quatre pour cent des votes en 2004 aux élections du Parlement flamand.
Depuis 2011, le parti entame toutefois un déclin électoral puisque toutes ces voix sont siphonnées par Bart De Wever, le jeune président de la N-VA, l'autre parti indépendantiste flamand.
La N-VA est aujourd'hui le premier parti de Belgique. Mais un élément pose systématiquement problème aux séparatistes, puisqu'au centre de la Belgique se trouve Bruxelles.
Et Bruxelles complique tout. Même si géographiquement, la capitale est enclavée au sein de la Flandre, Bruxelles est sa propre région et les Bruxellois ne se sentent ni Flamands ni Wallons.
Ils sont Bruxellois et c'est tout. Et comme Bruxelles est la capitale économique du pays, ni les séparatistes flamands ni les rattachistes wallons ne veulent partir sans.
La Belgique est donc aujourd'hui à un carrefour. Elle ira soit vers des régions de plus en plus indépendantes, soit vers une union plus forte, vers ce qu'on appelle le confédéralisme, ou bien au contraire, vers plus de refédéralisation.
Faut-il le préciser ? Si la N-VA plaide en faveur du confédéralisme, c'est aussi parce que cela rendrait la scission de la Belgique bien plus facile.
Comment la Belgique peut-elle fonctionner si les Flamands n'apprennent plus le français et que les Wallons n'apprennent pas le néerlandais ?
Et au fond, est-ce qu'un pays peut vraiment se scinder de manière tout à fait pacifique ? Est-ce que la Belgique est une fin en soi ?
C'est pour répondre à toutes ces questions que je rencontre aujourd'hui Philippe Van Parijs.
Et bonjour à tous. Aujourd'hui, nous sommes rejoints par Philippe Van Parijs, professeur à la KUL, à l'UCL et anciennement à Oxford, docteur en philosophie et en sciences sociales.
Philippe Van Parijs bonjour.
Bonjour.
Vous avez publié un essai cette année, à l'Académie royale de Belgique. Celui-ci s'appelle Belgium, une utopie pour notre temps.
Qu'est-ce qui vous a amené finalement à analyser la Belgique d'un point de vue historique et linguistique ?
Bon, c'est pas seulement d'un point de vue linguistique. Donc le livre que j'ai écrit est une vision d'avenir pour la Belgique.
Donc une vision que j'appelle utopique, mais c'est une utopie réaliste. Je l'appelle utopique parce que les différentes dimensions de ce que je propose
ne sont pas politiquement réalisables aujourd'hui, mais pour les rendre réalisables demain, ou après-demain, il importe de les défendre aujourd'hui.
Et c'est ce que je fais dans ce livre. La dimension linguistique est importante, mais elle est loin d'être unique.
Mais donc finalement, votre objectif pour une nouvelle Belgique, ce serait justement une Belgique plus confédérée ou plus fédérée ?
Plus de régionalisation ou moins de régionalisation ?
Mais d'abord, il faut comprendre les raisons pour lesquelles la Belgique ne sautera pas, n'explosera pas.
Donc parce que depuis longtemps, quand on entend parler de la Belgique aux États-Unis, ben on en entend parler que parce qu'on croit qu'elle est sur le point d'exploser.
En fait, il y a de multiples raisons pour être convaincu que cela ne se fera pas, mais ce n'est pas évident non plus.
Et dans le premier chapitre du livre, j'examine sans passion les différents scénarios possibles, les différents scénarios de scission.
On parle généralement du scénario de rattachisme de la Wallonie vers la France. Et j'ai même lu,
dans le chapitre un, justement, le rattachisme de la Flandre vers les Pays-Bas, dont je n'avais jamais entendu parler, mais apparemment,
certains y croient ou en rêvent.
Et oui, et vous expliquez que tous ces scénarios-là sont bloqués finalement par Bruxelles.
Oui, donc certains de ces scénarios sont bloqués par d'autres raisons. Là, vous évoquiez le scénario que j'appelle Groot-Nederland, donc le rattachement de la Flandre aux Pays-Bas.
En fait, récemment, je faisais une conférence sur le thème du livre, à l'occasion d'une remise de diplômes à l'université d'Anvers.
Et donc, j'avais fait voter la salle pour les différents scénarios, dont ce scénario-là. Et de dire oui s'ils l'estimaient le plus probable, sauf un petit coin de la salle qui a crié très fort.
Alors, j'ai demandé au recteur à côté de moi : « C'est quoi ces gens-là ? » Il m'a dit : « Nous avons un certain nombre d'étudiants néerlandais. »
Et c'étaient les étudiants néerlandais d'Anvers et leurs parents qui criaient très fort qu'ils étaient favorables, enfin, qui croyaient que ce scénario avait une certaine probabilité, alors que les Flamands, eux, n'y croient pas du tout.
Donc finalement, ce n'est pas tellement un mouvement important parce qu'il y a beaucoup de monde, c'est un mouvement important parce qu'il y a peu de monde qui crie très fort quoi.
Ben, c'est-à-dire, c'est un mouvement qui est sans importance parce qu'en Flandre, comme ailleurs, il y a personne ou très peu de personnes pour le défendre en Belgique.
Seulement, la question générale de savoir si la Belgique va se scinder, effectivement, si la réponse est négative, c'est en raison de Bruxelles.
C'est-à-dire, pour le formuler très simplement en deux phrases, ni la Flandre ni la Wallonie ne veulent quitter la Belgique sans Bruxelles, pour des raisons qui ne sont du reste pas les mêmes de part et d'autre.
Et la deuxième phrase, c'est que ni la Flandre ni la Wallonie ne peuvent quitter la Belgique avec Bruxelles.
Alors, si on ne veut pas quitter sans et on ne peut pas quitter avec, ben fatalement, on est collés ensemble à jamais.
Quand vous le présentez comme ça, finalement, la Belgique, ce n'est pas une fin en soi, ça n'est pas un objectif que tout le monde souhaite préserver, c'est surtout la moins pire des solutions, quand vous le dites comme ça.
Ben, c'est une solution, donc c'est pas vraiment une solution, c'est une situation dans laquelle nous nous trouvons.
Donc la Belgique n'est pas une fin en soi. Les Flamands ne sont pas venus habiter ici par amour des Wallons, ni l'inverse. Mais donc,
il faut se demander comment organiser la démocratie, non pas au niveau où il est le plus facile de l'organiser, mais au niveau où il faut que nous l'organisions
en raison de cette dépendance mutuelle, de cette interdépendance entre les trois régions du pays.
Ça nous ramène finalement aux origines de notre pays, à la Convention, à Vienne. Ce sont les grandes puissances européennes qui ont dessiné les cartes de l'Europe et ont dessiné
ce nouveau pays, ben de manière finalement assez artificielle. Et donc
on a finalement l'impression que les Belges
sont particuliers par rapport aux Français, aux Allemands, aux Hollandais, dans le sens où il n'y a pas vraiment un peuple belge uni par un héritage commun, par une langue commune, mais que c'est finalement un truc assez artificiel.
Oui et non. Donc
c'est évidemment une entité qui est artificielle comme n'importe quel État
est artificiel. Mais il y a bien sûr, entre les provinces dites wallonnes et les provinces dites flamandes de Belgique, une longue histoire commune qui n'a pas du tout commencé à l'occasion du traité de Vienne.
Le traité de Vienne a rattaché la Belgique ou a re-rattaché la Belgique aux Pays-Bas, qui eux, avaient acquis leur indépendance déjà à la fin du seizième siècle.
Et puis, il y a eu l'indépendance de la Belgique qui a eu lieu une quinzaine d'années plus tard par sécession par rapport aux Pays-Bas.
Mais bien avant cela, évidemment, les provinces flamandes, ou la plus grande partie
des provinces wallonnes et des provinces flamandes faisaient partie d'un même territoire qui était unifié graduellement par les ducs de Bourgogne à partir du quinzième siècle. Et donc,
cette histoire commune, elle existe en dépit de la différence de langue. Mais ce qui s'est passé, et ce qui est fondamental
pour l'histoire de Belgique, c'est que bon, on peut très bien fonctionner de manière multilingue pendant des siècles et des siècles, à condition qu'on soit en régime despotique.
C'est-à-dire qu'il y a un patron quelque part qui est un empereur, un souverain quelconque, qui décide pour tous les autres.
Il a quelques fonctionnaires un peu polyglottes pour faire tourner le bazar. Mais au moment où on devient
démocratique, donc on donne la parole au peuple, graduellement, en étendant le suffrage, ben on se rend compte que le peuple, il parle, mais il parle différentes langues.
Et donc, il y a une très célèbre prédiction du philosophe et économiste John Stuart Mill,
l'un des premiers à penser le nationalisme vers le milieu du dix-neuvième siècle, qui a dit
: « Une fois qu'on a des institutions démocratiques, on va voir une tendance à la coïncidence entre les frontières politiques et les frontières linguistiques. »
Précisément parce que la démocratie a besoin d'une opinion publique unie et cette opinion publique unie, elle a besoin d'une langue de communication.
Si on dessine les frontières politiques de la Belgique, là, on ne voit pas coïncider les frontières politiques avec les frontières linguistiques, mais au sein de la Belgique, on voit ce phénomène apparaître
entre les différentes régions.
Oui, mais en Belgique, donc, à mesure que le mouvement flamand s'est développé et a obtenu gain de cause dans ses revendications, à mes yeux légitimes, ben on a
construit une Belgique avec des zones, trois zones linguistiques initialement, donc à partir de la fin du dix-neuvième siècle et puis surtout alors renforcée dans les années trente où il y avait une zone,
une partie du pays qui avait une langue officielle qui était le néerlandais, une autre où c'était le français, puis une zone bilingue.
Et alors, petit à petit, on s'est rendu compte que pour mieux fonctionner, cet ensemble, c'était important de doter chacune des zones linguistiques d'institutions politiques.
Et donc on a vu effectivement se créer des frontières politiques, à savoir
les frontières internes de notre État fédéral, pour coïncider avec ces frontières linguistiques et ainsi permettre à la démocratie de fonctionner dans la langue et seulement dans la langue de la majorité de la population de ce territoire.
Donc, on a vu, au niveau interne de la Belgique, des frontières politiques commencer à coïncider avec des frontières linguistiques.
Et donc aujourd'hui, certains disent : Ben, la seule manière de vraiment assainir la démocratie belge,
c'est de reconnaître qu'il y a là deux démocraties et de scinder le pays de manière à ce que les frontières politiques, comme frontières nationales, comme frontières entre pays, coïncident avec cette frontière linguistique.
Certains disent ? Est-ce que vous en faites partie ?
Non, parce que donc ma position sur ce point, c'est non pas de se demander, ben, à quel niveau est-ce que la démocratie pourrait le mieux fonctionner ?
Parce que la démocratie n'est pas une fin en soi. La démocratie, c'est un mode de décision collective qui doit nous aider à prendre des décisions qui soient efficaces et qui soient justes.
Or, étant donné le niveau d'interdépendance entre les trois régions de notre pays, ce niveau, c'est nécessairement le niveau fédéral belge. Et on aura besoin--
on a besoin de la Belgique pour pouvoir prendre des décisions efficaces et justes,
mais non seulement d'une Belgique qui existe, mais d'une Belgique suffisamment forte en raison des interdépendances, en raison de l'intensité des interdépendances qui existent autour de Bruxelles.
Bruxelles, c'est un demi pour cent du territoire national. Ce n'est que le quartier central d'une entité métropolitaine beaucoup plus grande.
Et donc, si on avait fait un Bruxelles beaucoup plus grand coïncidant avec la province de Brabant aujourd'hui, on aurait pu décentraliser beaucoup plus de compétences, mais ce n'est pas possible.
Et donc non seulement on devrait garder la Fédération belge, mais une fédération belge avec des pouvoirs importants.
On a aussi l'impression que les tensions linguistiques entre le nord et le sud du pays ont augmenté
vers la deuxième moitié du vingtième siècle, quand la Wallonie, qui était autrefois une région très dynamique, très riche, poussée par la sidérurgie, par les mines de charbon, etc., s'est vue finalement appauvrie.
Le chômage a beaucoup augmenté, la criminalité a beaucoup augmenté. La pauvreté est bien plus présente en Wallonie qu'en Flandre.
Ce sont des phénomènes qu'on a vu apparaître surtout dans l'après-guerre, alors que la Flandre, de son côté, région plutôt agricole, a utilisé les fonds du plan Marshall pour développer de nouveaux plans économiques.
Est-ce que finalement, les tensions politiques, linguistiques, un petit peu identitaires aussi,
n'ont pas été augmentées par le fait que finalement, le contribuable flamand doive payer quelque part pour le pauvre Wallon dans sa détresse ?
Ben, je crois que ça fait effectivement partie du problème actuel. Ce qui s'est passé au fil de l'histoire, c'est effectivement que
la Wallonie, qui était, enfin deux provinces wallonnes, province de Liège et la province de Hainaut, ça ne valait pas du tout pour la province de Luxembourg, la province de Namur, ni pour le Brabant wallon.
Donc, il y avait deux provinces belges qui étaient, en termes de PIB par tête, de loin les plus riches du pays, si on laisse de côté Bruxelles et sa périphérie.
Et ces deux provinces jouissaient d'un énorme atout qui était la proximité,
entre l'industrie sidérurgique qui s'est développée, qui était essentielle pour le développement économique
de l'ensemble de la Belgique, de l'ensemble de l'Europe, de l'ensemble du monde, et la proximité entre cette industrie sidérurgique et puis les gisements de charbon,
dans la zone de Liège et dans la zone de Charleroi, Borinage, etc.
Alors, petit à petit, au fil de l'histoire économique, il y a eu une modification et ce qui était un atout à une certaine époque ne l'est plus du tout aujourd'hui.
Et par contre, la Flandre a pu bénéficier d'autres atouts, en particulier le port d'Anvers, la proximité par rapport à la mer du Nord,
mais aussi la prise en main de son propre enseignement à partir des années trente, alors que jusque-là, elle était
en quelque sorte, ça constituait une partie du pays qui était colonisée par les francophones, puisque tout l'enseignement secondaire et puis ultérieurement, tout l'enseignement supérieur était exclusivement en français pendant toute une période.
Et donc on a eu effectivement un renversement. Donc il y a eu un rattrapage et puis une inversion de la situation économique.
À partir des années septante,
la Flandre est devenue graduellement de plus en plus riche par rapport à la Wallonie. Et ça, effectivement, alors que la Wallonie ou la partie francophone du pays était dominante culturellement et imposait sa langue aux Flamands.
Et donc, si les tensions sont devenues plus aiguës à partir de ce moment-là, c'était que
la partie qui était non seulement la plus riche, mais la partie majoritaire du pays se sentait en même temps dominée culturellement, puisque quand les Flamands rencontraient des francophones,
c'était le français qu'il fallait parler, alors que les francophones ne faisaient aucun effort, ou que très peu de francophones faisaient un effort pour parler le néerlandais.
Oui, et on se souvient que, enfin...
C'est en 1979, je crois, que le Vlaams Blok a commencé son ascension jusqu'en 2004, où ils ont atteint, il me semble, vingt-quatre pour cent des voix au Parlement flamand,
pour ensuite, voilà, connaître un déclin et se faire annexer par De Wever, qui a siphonné toutes les voix du nouveau Vlaams Belang.
Donc finalement, aujourd'hui, on est un petit peu avec l'élection de la N-VA au gouvernement fédéral, on est un petit peu à un point de culmination au sommet de cette longue ascension.
Oui, mais enfin, il ne faut pas tout mélanger parce que la montée du Vlaams Blok et puis devenu Vlaams Belang, c'est aussi poussé par la xénophobie.
Bien sûr.
Et donc, hein, le-
Mais force est de constater qu'avec l'arrivée du nouvel acteur qu'est la N-VA, les voix se sont fait absorber.
Oui, se sont fait absorber parce qu'il y avait en même temps, évidemment, dans cette xénophobie, il y avait une dimension anti-wallonne qui était certainement présente.
Mais donc avant la naissance du Vlaams Belang, il y avait déjà la Volksunie,
qui a joué un rôle très important dans l'évolution du pays, dans la direction du fédéralisme, comme du reste, le Rassemblement wallon, le Mouvement populaire wallon,
et le FDF, le Front des Francophones bruxellois, qui, à un certain moment, avait obtenu une majorité absolue à Bruxelles.
Donc ces partis qui poussaient dans la direction du fédéralisme, d'une décentralisation plus grande, ont joué un rôle important avant que le Vlaams Belang ou le Vlaams Blok ne fasse apparition sur la scène politique.
Donc, mais si on met les choses en perspective, il faut bien dire que nos relations communautaires aujourd'hui sont beaucoup plus pacifiques qu'elles ne l'ont été, en particulier dans les années soixante.
Donc les moments de véritables violences, d'une certaine ampleur. C'était d'abord les grandes marches flamandes sur Bruxelles au début des années soixante et puis l'affaire de Louvain.
Par rapport à ça, la situation actuelle est vraiment pacifiée, grâce notamment aux réformes qui ont eu lieu suite à ça. Donc,
en l'occurrence, la création de ce qu'on appelait les communautés culturelles dans les années septante. Et puis ça, graduellement, ça s'est approfondi et
on a fini par créer un véritable État fédéral en 1993, 94, avec nos trois régions et nos trois communautés.
Oui. Donc, vous estimez qu'aujourd'hui, les choses se sont largement calmées et que finalement, une scission du pays aurait... Parce que,
je me souviens que quand j'étais dans l'enseignement secondaire, le professeur de géographie nous avait expliqué qu'il n'y avait jamais eu dans l'histoire internationale de scénario où un pays s'était séparé
de manière complètement pacifique et qu'il y avait toujours des cas de violence, des protestations, des manifestations importantes qui ont ensuite mené à une scission,
mais qu'un pays qui se scinderait de manière absolument politisée, voilà, derrière des écrans d'ordinateur, ça ne s'est jamais fait.
Et donc oui, est-ce qu'aujourd'hui, une scission, c'est véritablement imaginable ou est-ce qu'on est plus dans le fantasme de, oui ?
Mais donc, je crois que des sécessions non violentes sont possibles. Bon, on est en train d'en vivre une maintenant avec le Brexit, hein.
Évidemment, ce n'est pas une sécession par rapport à un État national, mais on en a vécu aussi dans le passé parce que la scission entre la Tchéquie et la Slovaquie s'est faite de manière pacifique, de manière suffisamment consensuelle.
Bon, ce n'est pas le cas pour d'autres sécessions, pour le Kosovo, par exemple, pour la Croatie, mais pour la Slovénie, bon, ça s'est à peu près fait de manière pacifique.
Mais bon, nous sommes évidemment dans une situation
différente aujourd'hui, même dans le cas de la Catalogne, où il y a eu une tentative de sécession alors qui a été réprimée, bon, sans mort d'homme, mais de manière quelque peu violente.
Bon, on se rend bien compte que, hein, les sécessions ne vont pas de soi. Et je crois qu'effectivement, ce qu'on peut exclure dans le cas belge, c'est une sécession violente.
Donc imaginer un scénario catalan, une tentative unilatérale de se séparer avec un référendum où la Flandre s'efforce, prétendrait quitter la Belgique avec Bruxelles, c'est quelque chose qui est tout à fait exclu.
Donc, hein, la force de cette double vérité qui est que ni la Flandre ni la Wallonie ne peuvent quitter la Belgique avec Bruxelles, ni l'une ni l'autre ne veut quitter sans Bruxelles.
Ben, hein, même si les raisons d'adhérer à chacune de ces deux affirmations vont évoluer au cours du temps, je crois que ces deux affirmations sont suffisamment fortes pour expliquer qu'à la fin de ce siècle, la Belgique existera toujours.
Quand on évoque ça, on pense à ces mouvements qui sont assez minoritaires en Flandre, où on voit des chants du Vlaamse Leeuw, des drapeaux qui s'agitent et des tendances qu'on assimilerait à une forme de nationalisme.
On ne voit pas du tout ça au Sud. Comment est-ce qu'on explique finalement que, voilà, ce nationalisme soit présent, bien que très minoritaire en Flandre, mais soit absolument absent de la Wallonie ?
Je crois qu'effectivement, il y a un nationalisme, indiscutablement un nationalisme qui est plus présent en Flandre, mais c'est en partie parce que la Wallonie manque d'un patriotisme qui lui serait bien nécessaire.
Donc, mais il n'est pas difficile de comprendre pourquoi ce nationalisme est plus fort en Flandre que dans la partie francophone du pays.
La Flandre a dû lutter pour son émancipation. Elle se sentait dominée par les francophones et donc le mouvement flamand a été un mouvement d'émancipation, tout comme il y a eu un nationalisme dans toutes les anciennes colonies.
Et donc le nationalisme, c'était un mouvement d'émancipation par rapport à une classe, à une élite dominante qui collaborait avec la puissance coloniale ou purement et simplement avec la puissance coloniale.
Alors évidemment, ce n'est pas tout à fait la même chose que ce qui s'est passé en Belgique, mais il y a une composante de gens là, ce qui fait que le mouvement flamand a grandi comme un mouvement d'émancipation.
Alors, il y a quelque chose d'un peu analogue quand même dans le mouvement wallon. Et aujourd'hui, on aurait peut-être besoin d'un peu plus d'agitation de coqs wallons en Wallonie. Aujourd'hui,
à mes yeux, c'est pour ça, je ne veux pas du tout une marche en arrière, mais au contraire une marche en avant qui permette à la Wallonie et à Bruxelles d'affirmer plus fortement leur identité et de développer une forme de patriotisme, bien sûr,
non racial, non ethnique, qui est essentiel au bon fonctionnement de toute démocratie.
Quand on parle d'une démocratie plurilingue, multilingue comme la Belgique, on pense inévitablement aussi à la Suisse, qui est un petit peu sa cousine, de ce point de vue-là.
Qu'est-ce qui explique que les tensions linguistiques soient bien plus présentes en Belgique qu'elles ne le sont en Suisse, finalement ?
Oui, ben,
il y a à ça-- donc, j'ai eu sur cette question-là une conversation que je rapporte du reste dans le livre avec
Micheline Calmy-Rey, qui était à l'époque présidente de la Confédération suisse et qui m'avait invité à Berne, dans son ministère.
Et elle me disait qu'à ses yeux, il y avait trois différences fondamentales. Et je voudrais en ajouter une quatrième qui, d'une certaine manière, était la source de ces trois différences qu'elle mentionnait.
« Première différence », disait-elle, « c'est que c'est plus facile de fonctionner quand on est vingt-six, les cantons suisses, que quand on est deux.
Parce que quand on est deux, si quelque chose ne va pas bien, c'est toujours la faute de l'autre. La deuxième raison, c'est qu'en Suisse, il y a des partis nationaux.
Et alors, et la troisième différence,
c'est que », disait-elle, « plusieurs fois par an, en fait, quatre fois par an, tous les Suisses, quelle que soit leur langue, quel que soit leur canton, quelle que soit leur religion, sont amenés à discuter au même moment des mêmes questions
en raison de la démocratie directe bien installée en Suisse depuis plusieurs siècles.
» Et donc, il y a des initiatives populaires. Ils en ont encore eu une dimanche dernier, donc, où il y a plusieurs questions qui sont soumises au oui ou au non dans le chef du peuple suisse.
Et je disais qu'il y avait une quatrième raison qui, pour moi, sous-tend les autres, qui est qu'en Suisse, on a eu d'emblée ce qui a dû être arraché
au Canada, en Espagne ou en Belgique, à savoir le principe de territorialité linguistique.
C'est-à-dire en raison de l'autonomie cantonale, hein, le fait que la Suisse, comme l'Union européenne, est née d'une confédération assez lâche initialement, donc avec une très forte autonomie de chacune des entités, eh bien, on n'a jamais eu
de francisation de Zurich ou de germanisation de Genève, parce que tous les germanophones qui s'installaient à Genève
n'avaient pas la possibilité d'avoir des écoles en allemand, savaient que toute l'administration était en français, etc.
Et de même pour les Genevois ou les Vaudois qui allaient s'installer à Zurich ou à Bâle. Bon, c'était l'allemand pour tout le monde.
Et donc, on n'a pas eu, par conséquent, en Suisse, la nécessité d'avoir un mouvement d'émancipation qui s'élève contre la domination, parfois formelle, mais parfois même tout à fait informelle, d'une langue par rapport à l'autre.
Et c'est au fond la non-compréhension de l'importance de ce principe de territorialité linguistique qui a conduit à l'affaire de Louvain.
C'étaient les francophones qui considéraient que c'était absurde de ne pas pouvoir continuer à habiter là sans piper un mot néerlandais.
Et c'est cette affaire de Louvain qui a conduit à la scission de tous les partis politiques, ce qui fait que c'est aussi en raison
du mouvement flamand que finalement, notre fédéralisme a été un fédéralisme avec ces deux grandes régions et pas un fédéralisme provincial.
Et c'est aussi en raison des tensions qui y sont liées qu'on se dit : « Ouh là là,
introduire la démocratie directe en Belgique, c'est beaucoup trop dangereux parce qu'on va se retrouver à la scission entre
francophones et néerlandophones qu'on a eu au moment du référendum ou de la consultation populaire sur le retour du roi Léopold III.
» Et donc, les trois raisons mentionnées par
la présidente de la Confédération suisse ont quelque chose à voir avec cette différence initiale qui fait que, par hasard, en quelque sorte, pas par une espèce d'anticipation
des solutions que ça pouvait apporter, par hasard, il y avait en Suisse un principe de territorialité linguistique bien plus solidement
installé et depuis plus longue date qu'au Canada,
en Espagne ou en Belgique, où on a eu des processus de francisation, d'hispanisation ou d'anglicisation, dans le cas de Montréal, qui ont conduit alors à des conflits beaucoup plus aigus.
Oui, quand vous parlez d'identité, on revient finalement à ce que certains appellent la belgitude, qui est que quand le Belge cherche à savoir
ce que c'est d'être Belge, il ne sait pas vraiment répondre, il ne sait pas vraiment définir ce que c'est.
Par contre, il sait surtout dire ce qu'il n'est pas. Et ainsi, la belgitude se définit souvent comme une entité en creux.
On dit : « Je ne suis pas un Français, je n'ai pas cette fierté, ce patriotisme qu'on peut voir à l'étranger.
» Mais d'après ce que vous dites, les Flamands n'ont pas non plus de réponse à la question « Qu'est-ce que c'est d'être Belge ?
» mais auraient une réponse à la question Qu'est-ce que c'est d'être flamand ?
Oui, mais être flamand, c'est entre autres être Belge. Et donc, c'est pas du tout antinomique. Donc, parfois, on voit ces identités comme étant des identités qui sont en conflit.
Effectivement, si on fait des enquêtes d'opinion et on demande aux gens : Qu'est-ce que vous vous sentez en premier lieu ?
Est-ce que vous vous sentez en premier lieu Schaerbeekois, Bruxellois, Belge, néerlandophone, francophone, européen, etc.
? Ben, fatalement, ça semble être un jeu à somme nulle. Plus il y a de gens qui répondent Bruxellois ou plus en Flandre, il y a des gens qui répondent Flamands, moins il y en a qui répondent Belges en premier lieu.
Mais il y a d'autres enquêtes d'opinion plus subtiles qui demandent aux gens à quel point est-ce que vous vous identifiez comme Belge ou comme Flamand ?
À quel degré est-ce que c'est important pour vous d'être Belge, d'être Flamand, d'être Européen ? Et alors, on constate qu'il y a non pas une corrélation négative,
mais une corrélation positive entre l'importance qu'on donne au fait d'être Flamand ou au fait d'être Wallon et au fait d'être Belge.
Donc, il n'y a pas du tout de conflit intrinsèque. Et donc,
être un bon Flamand, c'est en même temps, ça peut être en même temps être un bon Belge, parce qu'en étant Belge, ben on est fatalement un citoyen d'une des trois ou des quatre régions.
Pour moi, je demande à l'avenir, il faut qu'on voit la Fédération à quatre régions, mais on est à la fois un citoyen d'une de ces quatre régions et un citoyen de la Fédération dans son ensemble.
Et on a besoin d'un patriotisme à ces différents niveaux, depuis le niveau de son quartier, de sa commune, jusqu'au niveau de l'Union européenne.
On sait qu'au départ, en 1830, il n'y avait pas la Wallonie et il n'y avait pas la Flandre telles qu'on les connaît aujourd'hui.
Il y avait bien plus de patois régionaux et de petits, entre guillemets, dialectes, et que petit à petit, les régions se sont francisées au sud et néerlandisées au nord, pour donc devenir la Wallonie et la Flandre.
Et vous expliquez dans votre livre qu'il y a eu des tentatives pour que la francisation dépasse encore plus
les frontières de la Wallonie et englobe également le Nord, mais que ça n'a pas du tout marché parce qu'il y avait des résistances culturelles très importantes déjà à l'époque.
Oui, donc il faut bien voir que c'est ça que la France a fait. C'est-à-dire
à la fin du XVIIIᵉ siècle, au moment où la France est devenue une République, le pourcentage de Français qui parlaient le français était à peu près le même qu'en Belgique.
Donc, il y avait une cinquantaine de pour cent de Français qui étaient capables de parler le français.
Et donc, la France républicaine, jacobine, a utilisé le rouleau compresseur
du service militaire obligatoire et surtout, bien sûr, de l'instruction obligatoire pour imposer le français comme langue maternelle, ultimement, à l'ensemble de sa population.
Elle l'a fait par des mesures coercitives, notamment la circulation des instituteurs, pour s'assurer que les petits Bretons n'aient pas d'instituteurs bretons avec qui ils pourraient communiquer en breton, mais, etc.
La grande différence avec la Flandre à ce moment-là, avec la France, pardon, à ce moment-là, c'est qu'en France, ils ont un enseignement très centralisé,
alors qu'en Belgique, c'est tout à fait décentralisé et que c'était des initiatives assez locales, souvent par le clergé.
Ça empêchait finalement qu'une entité centrale, en haut du gouvernement puisse mettre en place des plans de circulation des enseignants, etc.
Puisque ça n'était pas vraiment, il n'y avait pas vraiment les leviers en main.
C'est vrai que c'est un facteur. Et donc, dans le compromis repris dans notre devise nationale, l'union fait la force, qui a rendu possible l'indépendance de la Belgique et sa stabilité,
en 1830 et dans les années qui ont suivi, il y avait une concession importante qui était faite par les libéraux,
aux catholiques, par la bourgeoisie libérale à l'aristocratie catholique et au clergé, qui était la liberté d'enseignement.
Et donc, ça a conduit à maintenir en Belgique, contrairement à la France, une part très importante de l'enseignement, primaire, secondaire, dans les mains de pouvoirs organisateurs catholiques, ce qui réduisait effectivement
la mainmise de l'État.
Mais néanmoins, on aurait pu très bien concevoir, à travers les contraintes imposées par le gouvernement national ou les conditions qui sont mises à l'obtention d'un financement, on aurait pu très bien concevoir une,
quelque chose qui soit analogue à la tentative française.
Du reste, même en l'absence de cette contrainte top down, en quelque sorte, venant des autorités, il y avait une francisation spontanée de toutes les villes de Flandre, parce que du point de vue
de l'ascension sociale, comme tout l'enseignement supérieur était en français,
y compris dans les universités de Flandre, donc à Louvain et à Gand, à l'époque,
ben il importait d'apprendre le français.
Et donc, les parents choisissaient d'envoyer leurs enfants dans des écoles francophones depuis La Panne jusque à Celte.
Et ça conduisait alors d'année en année à une francisation
des villes flamandes, donc, qui a été arrêtée en 1930, au moment où il y avait une obligation pour l'enseignement secondaire et primaire, une obligation de fonctionner en néerlandais dans la partie flamande du pays.
Ça, c'est le principe de territorialité linguistique dont vous parlez beaucoup dans le livre. Jules Destrée, homme politique du début du XXᵉ siècle, disait : Notre force belge,
c'est justement la libre association entre deux peuples distincts et toute fusion serait un amoindrissement.
Est-ce que vous le rejoignez sur ce point-là ?
Non. Donc
d'abord, la situation aujourd'hui est devenue telle qu'évidemment, on n'a plus seulement les deux races, comme
Destrée les appelait, mais évidemment, en Belgique globalement et en particulier à Bruxelles, bon, à Bruxelles, les deux tiers de la population aujourd'hui n'ont leur origine ni en Wallonie ni en Flandre.
Donc, il y a pas mal de fusions en cours et une fusion qui, à mes yeux, n'a effectivement rien de dramatique. Destrée croyait à la pureté de ces races.
Alors, il ne faut pas l'entendre en un sens strictement biologique, mais à une homogénéité des cultures et considérer que les Bruxellois, qui étaient un mélange des deux,
combinaient les défauts des deux races, comme il le disait, sans en avoir les qualités.
Donc, par rapport à cette affirmation de Destrée, ce sur quoi je le rejoins et sur le-- c'est un point sur lequel
Destrée est sur la même ligne que la N-VA, c'est l'importance de maintenir une identité qui soit propre à chacune des régions du pays.
Et cette identité, elle est bien sûr étroitement liée à la langue qui y est parlée. Et
la N-VA, comme Destrée, ont
le droit, je dirais, donc il est légitime, pour eux et pour d'autres, de défendre par conséquent l'exigence d'apprendre la langue de la région au moment où on vient s'y installer d'une manière permanente.
Et donc, ce n'est pas un-- ça ne veut pas dire qu'il y a un abandon de ses origines. Ça ne veut pas dire qu'il faut renoncer à sa langue maternelle ou à la langue qu'on connaissait.
À Rome, on fait comme les Romains.
Oui, mais pas sous tous les angles. Ça ne veut pas dire qu'il faut se mettre à pratiquer la même religion ou manger la même chose au petit déjeuner que la population locale.
Donc, il y a des spécificités qu'on peut
conserver. Mais l'apprentissage de la langue de la région, c'est une
exigence qui est tout à fait légitime, qui permet de préserver cette identité, une exigence qui est parfois coûteuse et difficile à mettre en œuvre, mais qui, pour moi, est légitime.
Oui. Donc le principe de territorialité linguistique, il est aujourd'hui dans le marbre. Personne ne le remet vraiment en question.
C'est vraiment inscrit dans la culture politique, ici en Belgique. Maintenant, dans les contacts interrégionaux, quand un Flamand parle avec un Wallon ou avec un Bruxellois, ou un Bruxellois avec un Wallon,
on remarque qu'il y a quelques problèmes de communication puisque finalement, de moins en moins de Flamands connaissent le français et les Wallons connaissent très, très peu le flamand.
Et donc vous faites ce constat-là et vous faites aussi le constat que les Wallons n'ont pas vraiment envie d'apprendre le flamand parce que ça ne leur sert pas tellement.
Ils ne sont pas confrontés
à des rencontres flamandes au jour le jour. Mais vous proposez comme solution, vous observez que l'anglais est de plus en plus parlé partout dans notre pays et qu'il pourrait devenir une lingua franca pour les communications interrégionales.
Et vous dites même que c'est déjà assez fort le cas aujourd'hui.
C'est en tout cas le cas pour les jeunes générations. D'abord, je vous reprends sur l'usage du vocabulaire et c'est une chose à laquelle les Flamands sont sensibles, c'est que leur langue, disent-ils, n'est pas le flamand, c'est le néerlandais.
Je fais souvent cette erreur, je ne sais pas pourquoi.
Et le-- Non, c'est un usage qui est fréquent du côté francophone, mais
moi-même, j'ai mis un certain nombre d'années à percevoir que c'était une chose qui était considérée comme insultante de la part d'un certain nombre de Flamands qui,
parce que justement, du côté francophone, hein, il y avait cette attitude à l'égard du flamand qui n'est qu'un dialecte minaire, minable, etc.
Et donc, il y a eu toute cette lutte qui faisait partie du mouvement flamand, vous y avez fait allusion tout à l'heure, qui était
l'apprentissage d'un néerlandais commun, hein, ce qui s'appelait pendant un certain temps l'Algemeen Beschaafd Nederlands, donc le néerlandais général civilisé, beschaafd.
Et puis on a supprimé le civilisé parce que ça faisait quand même un peu bizarre. Donc maintenant, on appelle ça l'Algemeen Nederlands. Et donc c'est
ce néerlandais qui est la langue de Flandre. Et comme vous le dites,
qu'on l'appelle flamand ou néerlandais, les petits Wallons comme les grands Wallons, les petits Bruxellois francophones et les grands Bruxellois francophones, ils ne manifestent pas beaucoup d'enthousiasme pour apprendre cette langue.
Tandis que du côté néerlandophone, la connaissance du français reste massivement plus élevée que l'inverse, que la connaissance du néerlandais-
Mais elle est en diminution malgré tout.
En Wallonie, mais elle est en diminution, en particulier parmi les couches de la population flamande qui parlaient vraiment très, très bien.
Il y en avait qui étaient essentiellement bilingues et des vrais bilingues en Flandre. Il y en a effectivement de moins en moins.
Et donc, de manière globale, la connaissance du français en Flandre se met à faiblir. Et ça, ça va de pair avec une amélioration considérable de classe d'âge en classe d'âge, donc des plus âgés vers les plus jeunes,
de la connaissance de l'anglais.
On vient de prendre connaissance maintenant des résultats
du dernier Taalbarometer de la VUB. Donc c'est tous les cinq, six ans environ, la VUB fait effectuer une enquête très approfondie, coûteuse,
sur la population bruxelloise quant à, entre autres, ses connaissances linguistiques, langue maternelle, etc. Eh bien la,
à Bruxelles, donc, qui est officiellement une ville bilingue français-néerlandais,
le pourcentage de Bruxellois qui disent connaître bien ou très bien l'anglais, qui était à peu près au même niveau que le néerlandais en 2001, lors du premier Taalbarometer, maintenant, avec des données de 2017, il est le double,
de la situation pour le néerlandais.
Et en Flandre comme en Wallonie, l'anglais a dépassé de loin la deuxième langue nationale. Donc, du point de vue de la connaissance parmi les plus jeunes, alors que parmi les plus âgés, c'était à des niveaux très différents.
C'était la deuxième langue nationale qui était la mieux connue.
Finalement, les jeunes qui parlent anglais et qui sont capables de discuter avec éventuellement les Flamands en anglais plutôt qu'en néerlandais,
ce serait par exemple des jeunes comme moi, puisque effectivement, dans le monde du travail, dans le monde
culturel, dans les relations que je me fais avec les jeunes Flamands, c'est effectivement systématiquement en anglais que je communique aujourd'hui.
Mais j'ai envie de me dire, mais les jeunes qui peuvent être dans ma situation sont des jeunes qui ont peut-être accès à une culture anglophone, à une culture américaine, qui ont ce luxe.
Et finalement, les populations qui sont peut-être moins privilégiées, plus pauvres, n'ont pas du tout accès à cette langue.
Et ont-elles accès au néerlandais ?
Non.
Encore beaucoup moins. Ils ont en fait beaucoup plus accès à l'anglais qu'au néerlandais. Ce qui fait qu'en raison de la diffusion de la culture populaire, en raison de l'accès à coût nul de l'Internet, où il y a une bonne partie qui
n'est vraiment, n'est pleinement accessible qu'en anglais, l'anglais s'est diffusé et s'est diffusé dans toutes les couches de la population.
Bien sûr, le degré de maîtrise de l'anglais est fortement corrélé avec le niveau d'éducation ou avec la situation sociale des personnes, mais c'est vrai évidemment pour le néerlandais aussi.
Et donc ma thèse, simplement sous cet angle, c'est qu'il y a un processus qui est à l'œuvre et qui fait que l'anglais va continuer à se diffuser et qu'il y aura de plus en plus de situations dans lesquelles un francophone et un néerlandophone se rencontreront.
Et au lieu de faire ce qu'ils faisaient dans le passé,
c'était systématiquement de communiquer en français.
Au lieu de faire ce qui s'est fait un peu plus tard, c'est-à-dire se taire l'un à côté de l'autre, parce que l'un n'est toujours pas capable de parler la langue de l'autre et l'autre ne veut plus s'abaisser à parler toujours
la langue de la partie minoritaire du pays,
eh ben petit à petit, on se trouve dans une situation qui est finalement beaucoup plus relax, beaucoup plus sympa,
où chacun fait l'effort pour être mieux compris de l'autre, de parler une langue tierce qui n'est pas sa meilleure langue, mais dans laquelle on parvient à communiquer.
Une langue d'appoint, finalement.
C'est un instrument, donc ça ne fera pas partie de notre identité. La langue qu'on a à apprendre, ce n'est pas la langue de Shakespeare, ce n'est pas la langue qui est représentée stupidement encore sur beaucoup de nos
sites web comme par le drapeau britannique.
Ce n'est pas une langue qu'on doit essayer de parler comme madame May ou monsieur Trump, c'est la langue qu'on va parler avec toute la diversité de nos accents européens et qui, par miracle,
est un joli compromis entre le français et le néerlandais, puisque l'anglais, ce n'est rien d'autre qu'un mishmash de français et de néerlandais prononcé d'une manière un peu nonchalante et qui sonne pas mal pour faire de la musique.
Oui, et donc, vous abordez le sujet de la culture. On observe de plus en plus de groupes de musique, de cinéastes wallons, flamands qui font des productions en anglais.
On parlait justement de l'emploi de l'anglais comme outil de communication interrégional. Est-ce que vous voyez l'anglais débarquer un jour au sein de la classe politique ?
Les auditeurs de ce podcast se souviendront qu'on a rencontré Alexander De Croo avec l'interview qui s'est faite en anglais.
Quand on suit le fil Twitter de, par exemple, Alexander De Croo ou d'autres politiciens flamands, les tweets sont souvent en anglais, même si ce n'est pas systématique.
Est-ce que vous croyez qu'un jour, on pourra aller à un rallye politique dans une Belgique où la circonscription sera faite à l'échelle fédérale ?
Aller à un rallye politique et entendre un politicien faire son discours en anglais ? Vous pensez que c'est imaginable ?
C'est une question de génération et il y a déjà des phénomènes, donc qui commencent à ressembler à des phénomènes de nature politique qui ont lieu en anglais.
Bon, un exemple, on pourrait dire, on est encore assez loin de la sphère politique, c'est au moment où notre équipe nationale s'est rappliquée de Russie pour être accueillie à la Grand-Place de Bruxelles.
Bon, il y avait un petit speech plus ou moins officiel aux troupes réunies, à la masse de personnes sur la Grand-Place.
C'était Martinez, l'entraîneur, qui s'est adressé à la foule en anglais. Et bon, les gens dans la foule ne sont pas retournés les uns vers les autres en se disant : Qu'est-ce qu'il dit ?
Qu'est-ce qu'il dit ? Mais ils se sont mis à scander : Belgium, Belgium, Belgium. Bon, là, c'est un phénomène sportif, bien sûr, à forte-
C'est un mot pas très dur à apprendre.
Oui, mais le discours aussi. Le fait que le bref discours assez élémentaire se fait. Le coach de l'équipe nationale belge s'adresse au peuple belge en anglais.
Alors là, on est dans une sphère hautement symbolique, proche, mais qui n'est pas encore la sphère politique. Autre exemple qui montre bien à quel point c'est un phénomène générationnel.
Une des rares manifestations qui avait un petit caractère communautaire, dans les années récentes, c'était la manifestation Shame, organisée par cinq gars qui s'étaient retrouvés par Facebook, cinq jeunes gars.
Et puis, un peu à leur surprise, ils se retrouvaient avec une manif de trente ou quarante mille personnes dans les rues de Bruxelles, plus ou moins improvisée.
Le titre de la manif, c'était Shame. Le sous-titre, c'était pendant la longue crise gouvernementale, c'était : No government, great country.
Et alors, je suis allé assister à la fin de la manif sur les arcades du Cinquantenaire. Là-bas, on a les huit
grosses dames qui représentent les huit provinces de Belgique, la neuvième, le Brabant, étant le grand char qui domine les arcades.
Chacune de ces dames a son nom gravé dans la pierre, juste en dessous, tout en français, Flandre occidentale, Flandre orientale, etc.
Parce qu'au cinquantième anniversaire de la Belgique, la Belgique fonctionnait encore intégralement en français. Et puis, il y a eu les discours.
Il y a eu un petit discours en français, un petit discours en néerlandais, un petit discours en allemand. Et puis le seul discours qui a vraiment animé toute la foule présente, c'était un jeune étudiant de la VUB qui a fait un discours en anglais.
Bon, là, on est déjà plus proche de la sphère politique. Un jour, autre exemple qui se rapproche là du cœur du fonctionnement fédéral belge.
Un jour, on me raccompagnait avec un collègue jusqu'à l'ascenseur. C'était le chef de cabinet d'un ministre fédéral et il me dit : « Bon, on a eu de telles
querelles lors des dernières négociations pour savoir si c'était le texte français,
la version française du texte ou la version néerlandaise du texte qui constituait la base de l'accord entre les partis gouvernementaux, que je suis sûr », disait-il, « que la fois prochaine
qu'on discute, on aura un texte de base sur lequel on se met d'accord, qui sera la version anglaise.
Et puis, on traduira ce texte vers les deux autres langues ». Et donc, tant pour des raisons pragmatiques que pour des raisons parfois de neutralité, l'usage de l'anglais est déjà présent.
Et donc, je suis sûr qu'il ne faudra pas attendre longtemps que des jeunes ministres du gouvernement fédéral, peut-être De Croo et un autre, un congénère francophone,
quand ils sont dans les couloirs, pas quand ils sont dans l'enceinte du Parlement pour s'adresser aux députés, mais que dans un couloir, ils discutent en anglais parce que c'est de loin la manière la moins laborieuse pour eux de communiquer.
Si ce n'est pas déjà le cas, oui.
C'est sans doute déjà le cas. Bon, je ne circule pas dans les couloirs du gouvernement fédéral, mais je suis sûr que c'est en cours.
Et donc, et ça fait... J'étais tout à l'heure à une réunion, un colloque organisé par, enfin, un dialogue organisé par le Conseil fédéral pour le développement durable.
Bon, j'ai dit que je suis sûr que dans
dix ans, il y avait du reste une partie qui était en anglais parce qu'il y avait des invités étrangers,
mais je suis sûr que dans dix ans, avec le rajeunissement, enfin,
plutôt le remplacement des générations plus anciennes par des générations plus récentes, eh bien, on fonctionnera intégralement en anglais, ce qui épargnera considérablement le coût de ce genre de rencontres, parce qu'avoir des interprètes
qui font un boulot formidable, ce n'est pas seulement plus lourd, ça rend les relations plus rigides, mais c'est aussi extrêmement coûteux et seuls peuvent se le permettre des entités suffisamment riches et suffisamment puissantes.
Oui. J'évoquais tout à l'heure la question d'une circonscription fédérale. À l'heure actuelle, les seuls qui peuvent finalement voter pour
notre Premier ministre Charles Michel, ce sont ceux qui vivent dans sa circonscription, c'est-à-dire le Brabant wallon.
Les seuls qui peuvent voter pour lui, ce sont ceux qui habitent dans le Brabant wallon. Et le reste des Belges ne peuvent pas vraiment évaluer ses performances pour voter ou ne pas voter pour lui.
Plusieurs acteurs de la classe politique, comme par exemple Alexander De Croo, ou je sais que plusieurs politiciens du Parti Groen en Flandre partagent également cette conviction.
Plusieurs acteurs politiques parlent d'installer une circonscription fédérale à l'échelle du pays. Je sais que vous en êtes partisan également.
Est-ce que c'est quelque chose que vous estimez probable ? Est-ce que c'est un mouvement qui prend ou est-ce que finalement, ça ne prendra pas ?
Je suis convaincu qu'on y viendra, hein, parce que quand vous dites que Charles Michel
ne peut pas être sanctionné par d'autres que par les électeurs de sa province du Brabant wallon, ce n'est pas tout à fait exact, parce qu'il est bien sûr vu comme étant le représentant du MR.
Ce qui veut dire que voter pour ou contre le MR, même à Virton ou à Verviers, ben, c'est aussi sanctionner positivement ou négativement.
Oui, mais de manière un petit peu indirecte, disons.
Mais de manière indirecte. Mais donc, ce point-là est important pour comprendre pourquoi la circonscription fédérale est importante.
Donc, tant qu'on avait des partis nationaux, ce n'était pas nécessaire parce que chacun des partis nationaux avait un projet qui concernait l'ensemble de la Belgique.
Alors, depuis la scission des partis nationaux, suite à l'affaire de Louvain, chacun des partis essaye de convaincre son propre électorat.
Donc, il y a une surenchère entre les différents partis de chacun des deux côtés. Et puis, on fait des promesses au détriment de l'autre communauté qui rapporte quelques voix et qui n'en coûte aucune.
Et résultat, on se trouve bloqué comme dans la longue négociation, les cinq cent quarante jours qui ont conduit finalement au gouvernement Di Rupo.
Alors, en raison d'un changement de stratégie
de la NVA, bon, qui, Bart De Wever, très intelligemment, a vu que ce n'était pas— s'il voulait aussi faire passer ses politiques dans d'autres domaines que le communautaire, ce n'était pas la stratégie qui fonctionnait le mieux.
Et donc, il a été décidé de mettre cette question, donc de ne pas avoir de discussions de nature institutionnelle pendant la présente législature.
C'est la raison pour laquelle les partisans de la circonscription fédérale ont aussi jugé que ça ne valait pas la peine de s'exciter pendant cette législature, du moins
jusqu'à la fin de la législature, au moment où il s'agira de déterminer quels articles de la Constitution il faut rendre révisables.
Et donc, effectivement, je suis, comme beaucoup d'autres universitaires, en particulier à travers le pays, partisan de cette circonscription fédérale.
En fait, on a créé en deux mille cinq un groupe d'universitaires francophones et néerlandophones défendant cette idée, qui a mis sur pied un site web qui s'appelle le Pavia Group, qui
a élaboré aussi une proposition précise, y compris indiquant
quels articles de la Constitution devraient être révisés et comment la loi électorale devait être modifiée, y compris dans le détail, parce qu'il est très important qu'on ait à la fois une représentation garantie de chacune,
de chacun des groupes linguistiques
qui soit maintenue dans cette circonscription fédérale, quoique chaque candidat puisse être,
quoique l'on puisse voter pour chaque candidat dans l'ensemble du pays.
Et il est aussi très important que tous les leaders de tous les partis soient présents dans cette circonscription fédérale.
Il est aussi très important que chaque candidat puisse être candidat à la fois sur une liste provinciale, donc dans une circonscription provinciale et dans la circonscription fédérale.
Donc, vous nous expliquez qu'on se dirige vers une circonscription à l'échelle fédérale, à l'échelle nationale.
Vous nous expliquez que l'anglais est de plus en plus utilisé comme lingua franca, en tout cas au sein des jeunes, mais tôt ou tard, ce sera les vieux par la force des choses.
Vous citez dans le livre John Stuart Mill qui, en mille huit cent soixante et un, évoquait le sentiment de nationalité commune des Belges, nonobstant leur diversité de races et de langues.
Finalement, si la classe politique se réunit et qu'on a des circonscriptions à l'échelle fédérale, si la lingua franca de la Belgique devient de plus en plus l'anglais,
est-ce que la diversité de races et de langues ne va pas petit à petit s'éteindre ?
Et est-ce qu'on ne va pas petit à petit observer une fusion ?
Non, parce que donc moi, comme vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure, je suis
un
avocat et un défenseur du principe de territorialité linguistique qui va permettre de préserver la diversité linguistique en Belgique et la diversité culturelle qui y est liée et qui va empêcher par conséquent la Belgique, comme elle,
cela empêchera aussi l'Europe, de former
un peuple en un sens fort du terme, au sens du grec ethnos, hein, d'un véritable groupe ethnique qui n'est pas nécessairement uni par sa race, mais est uni par toutes les dimensions de sa culture.
La Belgique ne se dirige pas dans cette direction et pour moi, ce n'est pas du tout un problème. Je crois que nous-
Ce que je veux dire, c'est que si l'anglais apparaît comme lingua franca et que tout d'un coup, les Wallons et les Flamands commencent à se parler, commencent à s'unir, commencent à,
à faire des bébés ensemble, est-ce que petit à petit, on ne va pas avoir, voilà, des gens qui sont à la fois Wallons et Flamands devenir petit à petit la majorité ?
Non, parce qu'ils continueront à parler en Flandre le néerlandais entre eux, y compris les immigrés de Wallonie qui viendront s'installer en Flandre parce qu'ils sont tombés amoureux d'un Flamand ou inversement.
Ben, l'essentiel de la communication locale continuera à se faire en néerlandais en Flandre et en français en Wallonie.
La situation bruxelloise est quelque peu différente, mais enfin, significativement différente. Mais donc, hein, ce qui est important, et donc
pour moi, dans le chapitre intitulé « Un demos belge pour le vingt-et-unième siècle », c'est important qu'il s'agit là d'un demos, c'est-à-dire aussi d'un peuple, mais c'est un autre mot grec qui désigne le demos de la démocratie,
qui requiert effectivement une langue, enfin, qui requiert la communication entre les personnes.
Et cette communication est évidemment facilitée par la connaissance d'une langue commune, mais qui n'a pas besoin d'être la langue maternelle de la majorité de la population.
Donc on a besoin de la langue comme instrument de communication, mais pas comme élément de sa propre identité. Et cette langue, qui sera notre langue partagée, pas seulement au niveau de la Belgique, mais aussi de l'Europe, sera l'anglais.
Et donc, la territorialité linguistique va demeurer, va rester. Et on se retrouve toujours avec le profil particulier de la Belgique, qui est une démocratie plurilingue.
Une démocratie plurilingue, vous dites, c'est laborieux et ça entraîne donc souvent la décentralisation des compétences.
Et c'est toujours, voilà, c'est finalement le,
le grand jeu de chaises musicales auquel on assiste régulièrement en politique, de savoir quelles compétences, quelles responsabilités vont au niveau fédéral, lesquelles vont au niveau régional, au niveau communal, au niveau communautaire.
J'ai cru comprendre, en lisant votre livre, que vous étiez adversaire aux entités communautaires et que vous voudriez plutôt renforcer les régions.
Oui, donc de manière globale, je crois qu'il y a vraiment
un élément extrêmement valide dans ce qu'on appelle souvent le principe de subsidiarité, c'est-à-dire tout ce qui
peut être décidé sans perte d'efficacité à une échelle plus réduite, hein, donc plus proche des citoyens, ben doit être décentralisé à ce niveau-là.
Donc, ce qui peut être fait sans perte d'efficacité au niveau du quartier, au niveau de la commune, etc., doit être fait à ce niveau-là et donc a fortiori aussi au niveau des régions.
Mais il y a des choses où les rendements d'échelle sont tellement importants, donc ce qu'on gagne à mettre des ressources en commun
est tellement important, ou des choses pour lesquelles les interdépendances entre les différentes communes, les différentes régions, sont tellement importantes qu'il importe de le faire à un niveau plus élevé.
Mais dans le cas où les différentes composantes d'une entité politique
parlent différentes langues, ou la langue majoritaire est différente dans différentes régions, il y a un argument particulièrement fort pour décentraliser parce que la démocratie fonctionne mieux si elle fonctionne dans une langue
qui est maîtrisée par
la grande majorité de la population.
C'est pour ça que l'enseignement n'est pas une compétence fédérale, mais une compétence des communautés.
C'est pour ça que ce n'est pas par hasard que c'est la première des compétences qui a été décentralisée dans l'histoire du fédéralisme belge, donc avant que la Belgique ne devienne un État fédéral.
Et donc, pour moi, hein, la transformation de la Belgique d'un État unitaire en un État fédéral, pour cette raison, est une très bonne chose.
Mais on l'a fait d'une manière assez compliquée, puisqu'on a à la fois trois régions et trois communautés et c'est, qui ne se recoupent pas.
Hein, donc alors, bon, je ne voudrais pas critiquer ceux qui ont fait ce pas parce qu'à mon avis, c'était un pas qu'il était utile de faire pour pouvoir avancer.
Mais on en voit aujourd'hui les limites. Et donc, pour moi, c'est important d'accéder à une fédération, à un fédéralisme belge beaucoup plus simple, purement territorial.
On aurait quatre entités, donc quatre régions qui sont bien sûr Bruxelles, la Flandre et la Wallonie, mais aussi Oost-Belgien, donc ce qui est...
enfin les neuf communes qui forment aujourd'hui la communauté germanophone et qui acquéraient un statut de région à part entière.
Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire concrètement ? Ça veut dire qu'un certain nombre de compétences exercées dans ce territoire par la Région wallonne leur seraient transférées.
Donc, hein, si elles exercent déjà les compétences en matière d'enseignement, de culture, mais des compétences en matière de milieu, en matière d'emploi, en matière de formation professionnelle, etc.,
leur sont déjà en partie transférées et devront l'être encore davantage pour que ça forme véritablement une région.
Évidemment, ça, c'est pour zéro virgule sept pour cent de la population belge. Évidemment, la différence principale concerne Bruxelles.
Bruxelles, c'est une dizaine de pour cent de la population belge sur un très petit territoire, mais une des
compétences vraiment fondamentales pour toute entité
politique qui est son enseignement, il est décidé à Bruxelles par des Flamands et des Wallons, c'est-à-dire par la Communauté française et par la Communauté flamande, où les Wallons et les Flamands, respectivement, sont majoritaires.
Or, il y a des problèmes spécifiques pour l'enseignement
bruxellois qui ne sont pas du tout pris en compte, en tout cas par l'entité qui a le contrôle sur les écoles qui accueillent la grande majorité des étudiants bruxellois, en l'occurrence la Communauté française.
Et donc, il est essentiel pour Bruxelles de prendre en main,
en toute priorité, son enseignement obligatoire, donc maternelle, primaire et secondaire,
et notamment pour pouvoir équiper les jeunes qui grandissent à Bruxelles des compétences linguistiques qu'il est à la fois possible et absolument nécessaire pour eux d'acquérir, alors que ce l'est
nettement moins dans la plus grande partie de la Flandre et dans la plus grande partie de la Wallonie.
Vous êtes pour la régionalisation de l'enseignement ?
Je suis pour la régionalisation de l'ensemble des compétences communautaires,
en préservant, et en premier lieu, l'enseignement obligatoire, mais en se rendant bien compte qu'on a besoin d'organiser alors les synergies
avec les autres régions, par exemple, au niveau de la gestion de la RTBF, donc des médias publics, au niveau de la recherche scientifique, du FNRS,
au niveau de l'enseignement supérieur, qui sera inévitablement transrégional du côté néerlandophone comme du côté francophone.
Mais pour organiser ces synergies, on n'a pas besoin de la confusion créée par un gouvernement séparé où il y a un pot-pourri de compétences
qui n'ont pas été attribuées aux régions et qui sont supposées être personnalisables, comme si toutes les compétences n'étaient pas, en un certain sens, à la fois personnalisables et localisables.
Dans un épisode précédent de ce podcast, on évoquait le cas de la révolution informatique au sein des écoles. Et voilà, quelque chose qui est très clair dans ce système politique en forme de lasagne qu'on connaît ici en Belgique, en forme de couches,
c'est que voilà, on a d'un côté
une ministre de l'enseignement qui doit décider des programmes et comment inclure l'informatique dans ce programme,
un autre ministre de l'enseignement supérieur qui doit décider de comment former les professeurs à inclure l'informatique
dans leur pédagogie et un troisième ministre, non pas dans la Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles, mais à la Région wallonne, qui est en charge du matériel, qui est en charge de la connexion Internet, qui est en charge des ordinateurs.
Et ces trois ministres travaillent dans respectivement le CDH, le PS et le Mouvement réformateur et doivent travailler ensemble et doivent
arriver à faire quelque chose d'efficace alors qu'ils ne travaillent pas au sein de la même structure et ne travaillent pas au sein du même parti.
Est-ce que vous pensez réellement qu'une régionalisation va faciliter ces synergies ou est-ce que ça va encore plus contribuer à une forme de chaos ?
L'objectif d'une simplification du fédéralisme belge, c'est de mettre dans les mains d'un même gouvernement toutes les compétences qui ont été décentralisées.
Parce que le gros problème du côté francophone, qu'on ne rencontre pas du côté flamand, en raison de la fusion de la communauté et de la région, mais du côté francophone, c'est vraiment complexe.
Je me souviens d'un colloque auquel j'ai participé à l'occasion du cinquantième anniversaire du pacte scolaire, donc du grand accord de 1958 sur le financement des écoles en Belgique.
Et un des orateurs était le ministre flamand de l'Éducation à l'époque, Frank Vandenbroucke. Et un des intervenants le félicitait pour le fait qu'il avait dans ses mains à la fois les compétences en matière d'enseignement, de formation et d'emploi.
En fait, du côté francophone, on a effectivement, non seulement on a des ministres différents pour l'emploi,
pour l'enseignement obligatoire, pour l'enseignement supérieur, mais ces compétences sont divisées, sont partagées entre ces gouvernements distincts.
Et donc, une simplification des institutions pour rendre les gouvernements plus responsables des conséquences de leur politique est vraiment une chose très importante.
Donc, ça ne doit pas se faire dans un climat d'hostilité entre la Wallonie et Bruxelles. Ça doit
bien sûr préserver toute une série de collaborations extrêmement importantes, mais cette simplification des institutions est de plus en plus soutenue par
des personnes au sein de tous les partis politiques.
Ouais.
Et donc, il faut y aller, il faut y aller d'une manière qui ne sabote pas ce qui marche suffisamment bien et qui préserve de bonnes relations entre les différentes régions.
Vous dites que c'est une position qui est partagée par tous les acteurs politiques ?
Non, non, non. Elle n'est pas partagée par tous les acteurs politiques.
Non, j'ai compris.
Je dis qu'au sein de chacun des partis politiques, il y a des personnes qui défendent ces idées.
Si on devait aujourd'hui prendre un petit peu la température et voir à quel point
ces opinions sont partagées, ce sera évidemment un sujet central pour les prochaines élections, les questions de régionalisation, les questions de circonscription fédérale.
Si on devait aujourd'hui prendre un petit peu la température, est-ce qu'on s'y dirige ou bien est-ce que la classe politique n'est pas du tout encline ?
Je n'ai pas de réponse à cette question, je ne suis que philosophe. Donc moi, je ne—
Vous ne prenez pas la température.
Et donc je ne me laisse pas guider. Et c'est crucial pour moi de ne pas me laisser guider.
Je ne demandais pas de vous faire guider. Je demandais—
Non, non, non, non.
De donner un aperçu.
Mais donc, je n'ai pas un accès suffisamment large ou équilibré à l'ensemble, aux opinions dans les différents partis politiques.
Mais donc, ce qui pour moi est important, c'est qu'il ne s'agit pas de se laisser guider par ce qui est actuellement
ce qui constitue l'espèce de consensus parmi les personnes qui sont au pouvoir, mais il s'agit de façonner ce qui est politiquement faisable en réfléchissant à long terme sur
ce qui est à la fois désirable et soutenable.
Et ça, ça affectera, même si ça prend toujours un peu plus de temps qu'on l'espérerait, ça affectera ce qui est politiquement possible parce que soutenu par une majorité dans les parlements et dans les gouvernements concernés.
Très bien. Philippe Van Parijs, merci. Ce fut très intéressant. Je dois à présent vous libérer parce que vous devez vous rendre à l'hôtel de ville.
Voilà.
On rappelle que votre livre s'appelle Belgium, une utopie pour notre temps. Il est édité par l'Académie royale de Belgique et on le trouve aussi en version électronique sur Amazon.
Chers auditeurs, à dans deux semaines. Au revoir.
Au revoir. Merci beaucoup et bonne lecture du livre.
Et voilà, c'est déjà tout pour ce neuvième épisode. C'est un exercice un peu compliqué de parler de la Belgique comme on l'a fait.
Il a fallu essayer de trouver un équilibre entre d'un côté les discussions pointues et de l'autre, ben, essayer de rester accessible.
Bref, je ne sais pas si c'est un plantage complet ou pas. Je ne sais pas si cette mission est accomplie ou pas. Et c'est à vous de me le dire.
Je compte sur vous pour me donner toutes vos impressions sur Twitter et Facebook. Il y a des liens pour ça dans la description.
N'hésitez pas non plus à me donner vos suggestions pour le prochain invité. Et à ce propos, il y a du très très lourd en termes d'invités qui arrivent en 2019.
Donc, pour ne rien rater, n'oubliez pas de vous abonner au podcast sur iTunes, Spotify, YouTube, Pocket Casts ou ce que vous voulez.
Allez, on se retrouve dans deux semaines. Bye bye.